we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're going to go to our next caller who
is calling in from the for10 area code
caller what's your name and where you're
calling from hi David
this is Shree your Asperger's medical
students on fan and soon to be dr. Shree
I'm calling from Erie Pennsylvania great
what's on your mind so I would like to
know if you're going to expand more
segments dedicated to people who have
gone through injustice because of mental
illness or behavioral health conditions
since that's my biggest passion and it's
a passion where I hope to take it to a
higher level globally in politics live
well I don't know that we have a plan
specifically for a segment by that name
cat do you have the list of planned
segments is that that's not specifically
on the list is it I can add it to the
list right now yeah I mean we certainly
talk about issues related to stigma
around mental health conditions on a
regular basis and I continue to keep
doing that and my family has many many
people who work in mental health and
different capacities and and I think
it's really really important do we have
something so specifically delineated
like you're suggesting I don't believe
so but it's certainly broadly speaking
something that we're going to continue
covering as we've been doing mm-hmm
because there's a lot of um cultural
nuances in family dynamics in how
injustice is magnified and that leaves a
lot of people left out more than even
middle class um advantaged upbringing
people who already have those barriers
so yeah I mean for me I think any
analysis ability analysis would have to
include as your astutely pointing out
the influence of class no question about
it so yes we will keep covering men
to health and stigma etc really really
appreciate the call